what's the most amount of houses you
bought at one time
i did didn't you tell me you bought like
a shitload of houses at once like like
a couple hundred well you know i sold
one guy like 56 houses i think in 90
days just buy and sell the same day
but you know we bought 18 unit buildings
we've bought
um beaches on the wall properties
underwater you name it i bought it
the thing is like when you say what's
the most i bought at one time obviously
i think
you know we could buy 50 i think we
bought 36 houses from one guy in the
deal
the way you structure it on the finance
i wonder if so you always want to pay
cash because
it's easier to acquire but at the same
time you want to use owner finance
this way you could control the deal with
the seller's money you could manipulate
the product using their money
yeah that's another thing that you were
telling me about you don't use banks
we had we had a long discussion about
that because there's a different uh
we were talking about another guy who i
used to deal with we won't mention his
name but
he uses banks and you were saying that
why use banks
well the thing with the banks the banks
are they want to lend money to people
who don't need money or people who are
desperate
because the government backs fha so if
you work at a
at a fast food chain and you're making
a tad below above poverty they're going
to lend you money because it's almost
they're forced
the dodd you know frank dodd act and all
that yeah so a guy who has money
and who's going to sell the property
immediately and they look at your track
record
they don't want to lend you money
because they can't see the profit in it
for them
the only way they're going to lend you
money is if you leverage it and hold it
for a certain amount of time
as a rental asset right and rentals are
cool for certain people because
it's it's like a fixed income but i
don't really care for the rental
business
no even though i don't like the money
rentals well let me put it to you like
this let's say you buy a property for a
hundred thousand dollars use round
numbers
and you rent it for a thousand a month
you're bringing in twelve thousand
dollars a year
by the time you pay your property
manager expenses for
taxes insurance maintenance you might uh
net eight thousand dollars so you're
working on an eight cap that's good for
an investment company because they're
borrowing at two percent so they're
400 times in their money but for a guy
like me who bought the house for a
hundred thousand i could sell it for 120
in one day
so i could make 20 000 i could make 20
of my money
in one day when i could make 8 000 in a
year and deal with the headaches
because most tenants ninety percent of
the time is a headache
um but how do you find these buyers so
like like when you say you find a house
right now you can go buy right now and
sell it like
how do you know who you're gonna sell it
to you already you just have like a
rolodex people you know you can just
like
i know this guy so you know on my phone
i probably got a couple thousand
people's numbers in my phone over the
years
and i know who buys what in what area
and what they're paying how they're
buying it
and you know there's a high demand for
the asset you know what i mean
so it's going to sell immediately at the
right price
let's take the hundred dollar bill
example for 98 you're going to have a
line a mile long for 101 dollars you
won't have one client
so you have to know the bottom the
bottom line the razor
thin line where to buy and where to sell
at
that's where the money's made
how do you so so you like i could look
you tell me tampa florida like i like in
the city limits i
i know most i'd say 95 of the streets
okay i don't look at gps i already know
what the house is worth before i get
there
right because everything is based on
retail minus the expenditures minus your
expenses
and most people want to make a certain
amount of dollar amounts so you already
know what they're going to pay before
they buy it
okay that makes a lot of sense you don't
really need money to make money in real
estate
what you need in real estate is either a
a buyer or b
us a product so like what i mean let me
tell you what i mean by that let's
pretend your mother has a house that she
wants to sell right
and it's worth 500 000 and it needs work
and i say hey
um how much you want for this house give
me 300. so i say look i'm willing to pay
320. so anything under that 320
that's money you made so if you get it
for 200 you just made 120 000.
whatever i sell it for is irrelevant
second if i
have a property and say hey look i want
to sell this for 250. anything over that
250 is the money that you make
so that's why it's easy to make money
without money in the real estate
business
you just need to have somebody in your
camp that can close
you mean come up with hard money come up
with the cash to buy because heart
it's hard to make money with hard money
it's really not an option for me
what do you mean it's hard to make money
with hard money well hard what you mean
is like doing like hard money loans
yeah hard money lending but yeah no but
getting back to that point what if
what if i don't have money and i want to
do that what if i don't have the cash
the capital to do it
and you then you got to do a hard money
like i was explaining previously in a
conversation i would try to get a loan
from the seller
right right right okay because if you
get a loan with the seller then you
don't have to pay for appraisals you
don't have to pay
points on the loan you don't have to you
know
beg daddy who basically is the bank to
help you
you mean you're you're going to be in a
positive position instead of
playing behind the eight ball right
but what if this i mean a lot of sellers
a lot of people who own single family
homes they don't have that kind of
that kind of money well you want to
target properties that are um
owned by the property owner that doesn't
have any debt
because remember you make money on real
estate by controlling the asset
owning it is just a a piece of paper a
deed you get a hud you go to the title
company now you own the property
right but you're not going to own it
that long so
if you could get a lease option even if
you could get if you could buy a house
for 300 000 here's five thousand down
i have a uh a recorded east option that
i could
assign to another buyer so you could
make money controlling that asset
without physically owning that asset
like i said real estate now you're
getting into options which is more
option can you explain like basic for
dummies
what an option is well basically on a
lease option is this you own the house
right and i make a lease to rent with
the option
to purchase it with the agreed time and
the agreed price
okay so and then what you put in the
lease
is in the in the purchase contract you
have an assignable option to sell
so let's say you sell me your house for
200 000
and then um my buddy wants to buy it for
225.
so he just pays me to 25 000 and he he
takes over the purchase
this way i made money with very little
money out of my pocket
because when you're first starting in
the real estate game with limited
capital
you need to acquire capital by any means
necessary
bringing other people to the table you
know selling their properties for them
you know stuff like that is it hard to
find new deals to make money on or are
people just
blowing up your phone all day every day
i mean are you on the computer like
scouring websites for [ __ ] for sale
no i never use the computer really my
phone
never use a computer no never my only my
only device i use is my telephone
and the reason being is because i have a
lot of people in my camp
that do certain things and i call them
and i say this is what i'm looking for
this is what i'm selling this is what i
got
so new construction is the the flavor of
the year
so it's like i hired engineers and i
hire people to do the work
while i own the asset then you hire a
builder then you hire a property manager
to manage the
you know project manager so then you're
just paying the draws
or you're paying the city for permitting
or whatever it is i try
not to get too deep inside the game
because then they people are going to
want something from you
they're going to want to take your time
they're going to want to take your money
they're going to want to pick your brain
and at the same time that's value so i
prefer to just have somebody on deck
that they could just
work through me and pay them but at this
current time to buy property is very
difficult
because the mark the market is extremely
hot
and the assets are very rare yeah it's
insane it's been getting hotter and
hotter over the past year
well when you look at real estate it's a
fast pace but it's really not and you
just have to use your mind you have to
take your mind in different avenues it's
like when like let me give an example
new construction
you already know what you're getting
into because you already know what the
product's worth after
before you even build it if a house is
selling for 300 a foot and you're
building for 100 a foot
your val your profits based on what you
pay for the dirt
minus your expenditures and then at the
same time
you're constantly looking for different
avenues to make money
like you know i've used car lots i mean
that's a dead business but you know
there's some money there
um anything that makes money and it
doesn't
take swallow a lot of my time that i
could pawn off to one of my people in my
camp
we'll figure it out because there's
always some way where
and when to make money but in the real
estate i like real estate because
everybody's your client
your mother your father your sister your
brother your cousin your neighbor
cause everybody lives somewhere every
everybody it's a necessity a luxury it's
um
it's an avenue to just make a lot of
money especially in today's day and age
because the rental income is very high
and we're in a market that's growing and
the interest rates are low
what kind of real estate do you own well
you know we own um
commercial real estate trailer parks
single-family homes multiple family
but when i own them to be honest with
you i did a bad job because i don't like
to own much i like to buy and sell it
immediately
you know i've probably bought a few
thousand houses in tampa alone
my thing is get it under contract and
and call one of my members and my team
to dump it immediately
90 of the stuff i bought i bought it in
one day and sold it the same day
but the ones the stuff i do yeah that's
insane
not really think about it logically if
you're buying 100 bills for 90 how fast
can you sell them
so because everything has a a dump price
you know what i mean
if you're looking at an asset you
already know what it's worth
based on the wholesale value and if
you're looking at the retail value
you're looking at it wrong
the money's made when you purchase it
now when you sell it you only realize
your profits as you sell but now the
game has changed because
you know we live here in florida tampa
st pete area
so there's a lot of people moving here
with no state tax everybody wants to be
here
and the properties have gone way up due
to the fact that
people from up north jersey new york
connecticut boston
and in california they're tired of
dealing with the state taxes dealing
with a lot of liberal
liberalism they just want to come here
and get out of that
and their houses are worth so much more
than ours so it's easier
it's easier for them to purchase